my name is Patrick been David I am half
Armenian half Assyrian my mother's name
is Donna bajo Sein she's Armenian my
father's name is Gabriel Ben David he's
a Syrian and the purpose of today's
video isn't just to bring awareness to
an event that took place 130 years ago
by the Ottoman Empire the Turkish Empire
against the Assyrian Armenian and the
Greek community witches wives called a
genocide the purpose was to wipe out a
community of Christians during that time
that till today many nations have
accepted this as a genocide in America
we have not yet accept this as a
genocide and by the way the purpose
isn't because I want to be a victim or I
want sympathy or empathy there's only 30
people in the world today who were born
during that time prior to that time in
Turkey who were directly affected by
this everybody else who is talking about
this event is simply mourning the
challenges the pain that their family
and their blood went through which
everybody Armenian a Syrian Greek we
have all the rights to talk about it but
I'm not here just to create awareness
I'm here to call to action to two
different communities to see what we can
do about this event here so one two the
president United States President Donald
Trump I like to take a direction that
maybe no one else has with you regarding
this event that took place back in 1915
and I understand every president that
has come before you has denounced it as
a genocide President Trump
President Obama called it a genocide
when he was a senator but I'm going to
became a president says it's not a
genocide others understand why there's
some Turkish political issues they were
going through and so when you become a
president everything is a deal I'll do
this and you do this and all this other
stuff however this is not a democratic
or republican issue this is history this
is a social issue this is something that
took place during that time that I feel
needs to be addressed but I'm gonna take
you from a different direction because I
know you're a businessman you're a
numbers guy and hopefully this will make
sense to you so in America in America we
have 330 million people that live in
America okay
the Turkish community in America is
roughly half a million the Census Bureau
says 206 thousand but let's say it's a
half a million Turkish Americans that
live in America on the other set a
Syrians have roughly 350,000 the
Armenian community is about 1.5 million
and the Greeks is roughly 3
this is five million on this side it's
five hundred thousand this is a
community of entrepreneurs business
owners artists creative athletes you
know job creators all these different
people in this community that keeps
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger so is this community
but we're talking five million people on
this side nothing against the Turkish
community but this is a grown community
and so for you watching this President
Trump obviously many of the people here
on this side didn't vote for you many of
them disagree absolutely what's your
political side that you have that is why
I believe it is so important for you to
see this as an opportunity for people to
say you know what I didn't vote for
President Trump I don't like what he
stands for but I cannot believe he is
the first president ever that came
through and did something about this
while many others made promises and
never did anything I think you get a lot
of love and respect from the community
say our president has courage to stand
up and say this isn't an event took
place I understand my Turkish allies
that are not happy about me saying this
but listen history is history is history
and this happened that's the president
Trump now to the Armenian Assyrian and
the Greek community I got a complete
different challenge for you and here's
what it is I heard what happened with
this past week with the Armenian Prime
Minister that ended up resenting because
a protesting that took place in Armenia
as well as all over the world which
means they were listening however if you
want America to accept this as a
genocide President Trump doesn't walk
the streets of Glendale he does not walk
the streets of Hollywood president Trump
walks the streets of Twitter I am NOT
trying to be funny no pun intended no
sarcasm no condescending nothing it's
just where he gets his news and where he
listens to his audience and I saw tens
of thousands of Armenians are protesting
right now one hundred one hundred plus
thousand based on some of the things
you're seeing out there can you imagine
I looked at Twitter Armenian Genocide
hashtag has only been shared less than
500 times today can you imagine if
200,000 Armenians Assyrians Greeks go
online and tweet at the president P o
tus hashtag Armenian genocide or
whatever the genocide is for the Greek
and Assyrian and all of a sudden he gets
100 200 300 thousand tweets
and imagine of all these protesting that
you're doing start telling people I
listen to this it's goat weed can you
tweet can you tweet at the president we
got the president text peers friends
Facebook shared this message with them
say let's tweet at the president if the
president gets a hundred tweets directed
at him don't you think he's gonna listen
a little bit more than just the things
that's taking place in the streets
because President Trump lives on Twitter
he doesn't live on the streets and
whether we like it or not you always got
to go to where that person is and the
place where the person we want that has
the influence the power to make this
change and call it a genocide he lives
on Twitter his name is President Donald
Trump and his handle is at P o tu s
address hashtag American Armenian
Genocide and share your feelings not
condescending not hate because no one's
going to hear it from that side your
heart what do your parents tell you
about this event what your grandparents
tells you about this event share that
with the President and hopefully our
president who's watching this will have
the courage to come out as he prays with
the people around him his advisers he's
gonna come out and he'll say this is an
event that took place I know a lot of
people are not happy about me making
this decision but if it is an event that
took place I want to make this thing be
known and we're finally gonna make April
24th in America every year the Armenian
Genocide they do Greek genocide in the
Syrian genocide they simply to address
an event that took place 130 years ago
thanks for watching everybody